Best messages in any given negotiation
are really implied,
indirectly come to the other person
based on thinking that you're getting
them to do,
getting them to get some really solid
thought behind their answers and so a
great thing to send someone an email is
have you given up on this project
because nobody likes to give up on
anything and at the same time,
nobody wants to say yes to that because
they don't know what they're letting
themselves in for when they say yes.
You know what?
It's interesting because that particular
email has restarted negotiations that
I've seen dead silence for weeks prior
to that and simply sending that email
all by itself and in many cases you can
get a response within three to five
minutes of reading the email or the
text.
That's a great way to get things
restarted.
Now,
the problem with that is there's a
really good chance you contributed to
the silence in the first place
and your next move when they respond is
you've got to get a that's right out of
them next because they have to feel like
that their communication is being paid
attention to.
Summary is designed to let the other
side know that you really understand
what's going on now,
and if nothing else,
at least you understand their position.
There are a lot of negotiators that
really will give in on a deal because
being understood is more important than
getting what they want in particular.
Um,
the assertive negotiator being
understood is actually more important to
them than,
than actually making the deal.
So everybody wants to be understood
anyway.
Let people know you completely
understand where they're coming from and
that's the design of a summary,
summarizing the facts and how they feel
about the facts and actually if you can
summarize their feelings about the facts
that are driving them,
but that they're blind to will make a
big difference to them because then they
feel really understood that empathy
connection is there and they may
actually change their mind about what
decisions they've made.
One empathy has been established.